j'ai 23 ans et ce matin quand je me suis
réveillé je me suis rendu compte
soudainement que j'étais en train de
devenir un adulte quand j'étais contente
faut qu on se rend compte de ce genre de
choses c'est jamais dans les grands
moments de ta vie j'avais quand tu vas
commencer ton premier jour de travail ou
quand tu vas faire ton mariage ou ta
communion non c'est toujours dans les
mouvements un peu nul c'est fini
l'époque où tu pouvais te la péter avec
ta monde flik flak à l'école au oui non
monsieur à 80 a pas une once flik flak
t'as raté ta raté ta vie
bon après après la fini les soirées
darty est haute et crie ton nom ce sont
des gobelets et put et diderot de
l'alcool maintenant tu fais ce qu'on
appelle des dîners ou pire des apéritifs
dînatoires je t'appelais pour savoir si
tu voulais passer un moment complètement
austère autour d'une table carrée cents
environ sans musique sans rien un peu
nul hein quoi pas de musique pas
d'ambiance pas de filles mais c'est
génial j'arrive pièce parfait bien être
une belle occase à quand tu te dis un
adulte qui rentre dans une nouvelle ère
l'ère administratif à dompter la
sécurité sociale qui te rembourse une
partie
et puis l'autre partie c'est la mutuelle
quitte la renvoie en fait un mois que tu
sois à la sécurité sociale étudiante
alors que fanta 17 ans tu t'en fous de
la mutuelle tu penses à deux choses à
mes gosses
maintenant je deviens un adulte chez des
potes adultes ça me dérange pas d'avoir
des amis adultes humaine problème c'est
qu'ils font souvent des blagues que je
comprends pas tu vas bombardé picasso et
pizarro bien c'est bien connu les filles
elles sont souvent plus rapidement
adultes que les garçons et d'ailleurs
c'est plutôt agréable de discuter avec
elle
franchement tout n'est pas dit long
france 1 pi genre ancien hippie revoilà
toi et moi on a vingt trois ans mais je
te considère comme impurs ministre pisse
dessus
[Musique]
je vais voir les filles 2 cm de large
avantage au maire ait envoyé trop noël
ton anniversaire une petite enveloppe
avec un peu d'argent et peut acheter un
petit cadeau avec je faisais plaisir
enfin mais maintenant c'est fini
un chèque de ma grand mère c'est trop
gentil parfait je vais pouvoir payer un
vingtième de mon loyer parfois ça
m'arrive de faire des trucs de jeunes
des fois je me rappelles tu suis un
adulte alors je culpabilise et je me
sens mal pourquoi je fais ça c'est
complètement stupide j'ai un adulte
maintenant moi tout ça ça me fait un peu
peur j'ai peur que bientôt on en voit
comme aux parents des textos avec des
points entre les noms bonjour pour le
fiston point ça points
ras les mecs de mon âge qui sont déjà
devenus adultes en soirée ils portent
tous des chemises
rassurez moi les mecs je suis pas le
seul dans ce cas enfin moi quand je
monte chemise ça fait pas un autre ça
fait pas comme un ami
moi ça fait l'effet voile de bateau ça
me tient un coup de vent ont la soirée
où je suis a traversée de la manche
non mais sérieux ils font comment la
mecque pour porter leur chemise mois
encore n'accepte pas la chemise je
refuse de porter ce vêtement
j'ai encore un truc c'est encore plus
compliqué c'est la cravate des formes de
nombre de porter une cravate en soirée
et moi je stresse pas ce que je sais pas
faire les noeuds regardent sur internet
sur google com en faire un noeud de
cravate
[ __ ] mais j'ai quand même toujours
peur d'arriver en soirée comme ça vous
regarde
l'ong excellent je refuse de devenir un
adulte mais ce n'est là pour fait
maintenant il ya une page facebook
norman fait des vidéos ça aille c'est ça
[Musique]